alexandre langlois bonjour d'être en
direct avec nous par téléphone
votre première réaction à cette cette
révocation
comment est ce que vous êtes dans quel
état d'esprit est ce que vous êtes après
cette décision
je suis combatif parce que
malheureusement je m'y attendais qu' il
ya des décisions politiques qui allait
tomber
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé monsieur
d'arbanats a choisi tout seul demeurez
qu'évoquer de la police nationale parce
qu'ils ne supportent pas la liberté
d'expression aujourd'hui donc que
j'avais proposé de quitter la police est
une rupture conventionnelle il n'a pas
donné suite il n'a juste pas répondu
donc il a choisi ce côté là pour en plus
d'un cadre de baux de la sécurité faire
passer un message à tous les
syndicalistes en disant si jamais vous
n'avez pas dans le sens du gouvernement
attention nous avons les moyens de vous
révoqué et comment est ce que vous avez
appris cette cette révocation dans la
lettre datée du 12 mars que vous avez
reçu du ministre de l'intérieur vous est
reproché une publication du 18 janvier
2020 dans laquelle vous reprocher je
cite une liste de griefs outrancier au
directeur général de la police nationale
monsieur éric morvan est ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus alors moi je l'
ai appris en allant tout simplement
travailler hier matin on m'a dit écoutez
on a quelque chose à vous de faire
signer donc dans l'après midi à 16
heures j'ai découvert de steve van
persie n'est donc c'était ma révocation
est ensuite est ce que je reprochais au
nom du syndicat à monsieur morvan et ses
défaites là outrancier dans la façon de
dénoncer ce fait est fait et qu'il me
114 suicide pendant qu'il était
directeur de la police nationale tu as
fait nous annonçant que tous nos
collègues qui sont morts il ya un vrai
tabou dans la police parce que la
semaine dernière quand nous avons eu ce
faire une manifestation avec deux
organisations
le préfet de police a interdit le
rassemblement de policiers pour la lutte
contre le suicide
la deuxième chose c'était une agression
sexuelle d'un médecin police dans l'est
de la france qui a été condamné par la
justice
mais pareil népalais pas le dénoncer et
nous avons également des chiffres de la
délinquance qui sont falsifiés en audit
interne l'a confirmé ne fallait pas le
dénoncer donc c'est des choses graves
qui sont des faits et l'administration a
dit que c'était la forme qui la désole
voilà où on en est en france donc vous
des dents c'est une décision politique
c'est ça selon vous
vous étiez devenu trop gênant la
décision est clairement politique parce
que le conseil de discipline ne s'était
pas prononcée tous les syndicats de la
police nationale unanimement ont refusé
de prendre part à ce vote en disant
qu'il n'était pas compétent pour juger
un syndicaliste qui en plus par ailleurs
bien noté donc effectivement c'est bien
la liberté d'expression qui est attaqué
de façon beaucoup plus général et du
coup oui c'est une décision politique
parce que c'est le ministre tout seul
qui a décidé de me sanctionner contre
l'avis de tout le monde donc là alors on
nous parle on vous nous le confirme vous
nous le confirme et vous n'avez toujours
pas signé cette révocation donc vous
êtes toujours secrétaire général du
syndicat de police visi j'ai filé la
révocation
hier et depuis ce matin je ne suis pas
policier par contre je suis toujours
secrétaire général du syndicat vigie et
je le resterai jusqu'au tour au prochain
congrès parce que dans nos statuts nous
avions prévu c'est d'entourloupe de
l'administration qui abuseraient de son
pouvoir disciplinaire pour faire taire
des délégués nous n'avions pas pour ça
que ce serait le secrétaire général et
quel recours judiciaires donc suite à
cette décision vous disiez tout à
l'heure que vous étiez dans un état
d'esprit combatif bas la décision ça va
être de dire partir à l'attaqué en
référé suspensif et en référé sur le
fond pour bat déjà suspendre la décision
du ministère et puis après les sur le
fond pour faire casser la décision
définitivement mais à côté de ça je me
dis que je vais être combatif parce
qu'il ya plein de collectif
d'associations qui m'avait contacté pour
travailler avec elle sur des différentes
réformes démocratie lit comme on pouvait
organiser les choses bien écouté comme
ça j'aurai du temps de mener tous ses
combats qui dépasse la politique du coup
justement on parle de votre état
d'esprit à vous mais quel est l'état
d'esprit
de vos collègues de de vos compagnons de
route entre guillemets
est ce que vous sentez soutenu au sein
de la police
quelles sont les réactions suite à cette
décision concernant vos proches et vos
confrères alors les proches dans les
gens dans mon service ils ont été
choqués et bien évidemment les collègues
avec qui je travaille tous les jours
elle aura fait un choc ils n'ont pas
compris que ce soit révoqué alors que
des personnes qui tiennent des propos
racistes qui font des bd des manquements
plus graves à la déontologie et des
blâmes ou des avertissements après sur
mes collègues du syndicat bien
évidemment tout le monde est choqué mais
on sait qu'on est un syndicats combatifs
et encore récemment c'est qu'on va être
sous le feu de l'actualité parce que l
affaire benalla revient sur le devant de
la scène le procureur ayant demandé que
monsieur ben à la passe en
correctionnelle et nous sommes donc
partie civile dans cette affaire et plus
largement j'ai eu quelques syndicalistes
d'autres syndicats d'autres collègues
d'autres associations et qui m'ont dit
qu'ils étaient choqués qu'ils n'étaient
pas forcément d'accord avec sont
proposées au niveau du syndicat vigie
mais pour le coup qui voulait quand même
garder la liberté d'expression donc pour
moi c'est un état de consternation
encore plus de le rappeler dans un cadre
de baux de la sécurité où on demande aux
gens de venir débattre mais avec un
couteau sous la gorge du coup est ce que
vous estimez être un lanceur n'alerte
pas c'est ce que j'ai dit oui parce que
effectivement mois de camp quelqu'un se
suicider meurent parce que
l'administration est incapable
d'organiser convenablement le travail et
de prendre soin d'eux d'effectifs oui je
suis un menteur de l'aird parce que
malheureusement le premier pourvoyeur de
morts 2 policiers
ce ne sont pas les criminels mais tu es
notre propre institution qui nous pousse
au désespoir donc oui je suis un menteur
dallaire en ce moment il ya une
manifestation contre la loi sécurité
globale qui concerne donc les forces de
l'ordre votre point de vue par rapport à
ça sachant qu'une manifestation qui a
lieu également en ce moment même c'était
une des motivations qui avait poussé à
ma demande de rupture conventionnelle
parce que cette loi est juste un
artifice pour empêcher la liberté de la
presse nous sommes toujours sur des
libertés fondamentales que ce
gouvernement
le supprimer ya une île et parce que on
nous a dit que c'était pour protéger les
policiers des protéines et des policiers
ont été suivies ont été harcelés sur des
réseaux sociaux
la personne avait été condamné à dix
sept mois de prison ferme sans la loi
donc nous sommes sur du bricolage de
l'habillage pour une loi qui ne porte
pas son nom on essaie de dire c'est pour
la protection des policiers ce n'est pas
du tout ça donc et belfort gagner dès
les pouvoirs et surtout défendre les
libertés individuelles qui est bien sûr
à l'opposé des propositions actuellement
fait
dernière question alexandre
voici la révocation devait se confirmer
malgré les recours juridiques
quelle serait la suite pour vous est-ce
que vous avez déjà pensé à ça est ce que
vous changeriez de voir si vous laquelle
ben je ne changerais de roy oui je vais
prendre un peu de hauteur
dire que là j'étais concentré sur les
libertés publiques vis-à-vis d'un prix
que nos policiers
là j'ai été sollicité sur d'autres
libertés individuelles d'autres libertés
fondamentales qui sont bas fruits donc
j'espère pouvoir soit trouvé les
ressources nécessaires pour en vivre ou
sinon bah de trouver des travaux d un
travail alimentaire pour pouvoir
continuer ces combats qui me semble
important parce que l'état la démocratie
fait peine à voir aujourd'hui je ne peux
pas laisser un monde pareil à des
enfants merci alexandre lang d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes donc toujours secrétaire
général du syndicat de police
vigie et que vous avez donc signé la
lettre de révocation
donc du ministère de l'intérieur merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct et en exclusivité donc sur sur rt
france